okay so i would like to thank the
organizers for inviting me to
participate today and I'm excited to
talk to you about our project on
subtyping circulating tumor cells and
breast cancer so basically we're
interested in capturing a heterogeneous
subset of circulating tumor cells and
then we have chosen to use a novel
technology that allows us to isolate
single circulating tumor cells that are
appropriate for downstream analysis so I
am a fellow a clinical chemistry fellow
at the University of Louisville in the
department of pathology and my mentors
are dr. mark lender and dr. Roland
Valdez so this project was done in
conjunction with them so unfortunately I
have no disclosures to report and I'd
like to also remind everyone that if you
have any questions you can go ahead and
type them in as they come to mind and
then I'll answer them at the end of the
presentation so just to give everyone a
little bit of an outline about where I'm
headed with my talk today first I'll
give a background on circulating tumor
cells including the FDA cleared method
to enumerate them as well as touch on a
few other technologies that have been
developed to to characterize CTCs I'll
talk a little bit about some of the
clinical trials that are currently going
on and then I'll go into the the three
main limitations as we see the field of
circulating tumor cells and what we're
doing to to advance those limitations so
what is a circulating tumor cell this is
a schematic of a blood vessel so here
you see the epithelium the basement
membrane and then the layer of
endothelial cells and
the blood vessel so in Part B of this
schematic we see a primary tumor and so
circulating tumor cells are thought to
be cells that have been shed from that
primary tumor and have intravascular
those cells then have the potential to
form metastatic lesions in the patient
so these cells are very dangerous to the
patient more so than what's in the
primary tumor because most patients the
mortality comes from metastatic cancer
and not the primary tumor these cells
are really poorly defined I'll go into
what the current definition isn't a
little bit but we really feel that we
don't have the best definition of what a
circulating tumor cell is in order to to
capture a heterogeneous set of ctcs
these cells are very difficult to study
because they're in such low abundance so
in one mill of whole blood there may be
10 million white blood cells and five
billion red blood cells and a metastatic
breast cancer patient may have on the
order of 100 circulating tumor cells so
they're very difficult to study because
of their extreme low abundance and we're
interested in setting these because they
hold such promise of prognostic value to
the patient so what is a circulating
tumor cell the current definition most
people agree is the definition that's
given by cell search which is the only
fda-cleared method for enumerated CTCs
and may define a circulating tumor cell
as a large nucleated cell one did a cd45
negative so cd45 is a market for
leukocytes so it is not a mathematical
edexcel these cells are epithelial cell
adhesion molecule positive or fkm
positive which is a marker of epithelial
cells
the cells must also stain positive for
cytokeratin 8 18 or 19 which is an
intracellular marker of epithelial cells
this definition really describes a
specific type of epithelial CTC and we
believe that this strict definition may
not allow all this all what really are
circulating tumor cells to be detected
so we're interested in potentially
expanding this definition so how does
the FDA cleared a method work as an
independent predictor of outcome so this
test uses seven and a half mills of
whole blood from from the breast cancer
patient and in that seven and a half
mils of blood if the patient has five or
greater circulating tumor cells they're
associated with a worse prognosis or
specifically less than 11 months of
overall survival but if they have fewer
than five CTCs their associated with
better prognosis specifically greater
than 18 months of overall survival and
this test has been validated over and
over again and these values are very
consistent but what I'd like to point
out is that this test really only
provides enumeration of circulating
tumor cells there's no more
characteristics about the individual
CTCs that are given other than how many
epithelial type CDC the patient has and
so we're interested in providing more
specific characterization of a patient's
CTCs so I'm just going to go through a
couple of examples of what CDC's how
they're being studied in clinical trials
so there are
many clinical trials currently going on
looking at circulating tumor cells right
now I'm just going to list a few that I
think are interesting so one that has
just finished is a study that's looking
at the effects efficacy of lapatinib in
patients that have an on her to
amplified primary tumor but have a
positive her2 circulating tumor cell so
this study showed a reduction in
her2-positive CTCs so that's very
promising in this particular study no
clinical response was determined but
these types of studies are very
important to look at treating the
patient based on their circulating tumor
cells instead of just the primary tumor
we think that that will give a better
therapeutic regimen for the patient
another example this one's currently
ongoing is looking at an endocrine
therapy index so in this study they're
examining markers of endocrine
sensitivity and resistance and they've
come up with an algorithm to predict the
endocrine therapy index or eti and this
is for patients that have ER positive
her2 negative metastatic breast cancer
and so the goal of this study is to
provide the best endocrine therapy for
an individual based on their circulating
tumor cells in the last example that
I'll give of an ongoing clinical trial
involving circulating tumor cells is one
using the CTC chip device that I'll
explain a little bit more in a minute so
this clinical trial is looking at
comparing the EGFR mutation on the CTC
to the tumor itself and so everyone
believes that CTCs have great promise to
be used as a surrogate for a tumor
biopsy because it's less than
vasive to the patient and can be done
more often so what are captured devices
that are currently being used for
circulating tumor cells so as I
mentioned the FDA cleared method the
cell search is the one that's most
widely used and has been extensively
validated in this method they perform a
cd45 negative enrichment so they deplete
the hematopoietic cells they use a
ferrofluid containing AB Kim antibodies
to enrich for circulating tumor cells so
they're capturing only those CDC's that
have that at cam marker so those those
CDC's that are epithelial in nature they
did they then identify that that
circulating tumor cell is in fact a CTC
by staining for cytokeratin 8 18 or 19
and this process is highly automated and
it's the most widely used method for
clinical trials the limitations of this
method are of course that the cell must
express the epithelial marker AB cam and
the cells must be permeable eyes to look
at cytokeratin because it's an
intracellular marker and so because the
cells must be permeable eyes that limits
the type of downstream analysis or
characterization that can be performed
so we're interested in using a method
that I'll talk about in a little while
that eliminates the need for the cell to
be permeable eyes so that we can
characterize a performed on stream
characterization so this is one of the
new devices that's garnered a lot of
attention to detect circulating tumor
cells this method is the first iteration
of this was the CDC chip and I believe
this was a
a collaboration of mass gen and Harvard
I think and they use diluted whole blood
on what they are now calling the second
version is the herringbone ship and
here's a schematic of this device and
this device has garnered a lot of
attention and as looks like one of the
new promising methods to detect CDC's so
the herringbone ship applies passive
mixing of blood cells through the
generation of micro vortices to
significantly increase the number of
interactions between targets ETCs and
the antibody coded chip and they've
showed the ability to produce efficient
capture of ctcs using this method so I
believe that will see more with this
with this device another one and these
are just examples there are many devices
that are being developed to to look at
circulating tumor cells this one's known
as the mag sweeper I believe from the
group at Stanford they use a robotic of
robotic arm to collect cells that are
labeled with that Kim antibodies this is
nice because it's very highly automated
um and again a limitation with this
method is that not all CDC's express F
cam so there'd be missing any CBC's that
may not be epithelial and then lastly
this is an interesting method i set it
stands for isolation of epithelial
tumors so they use size to enrich for
their tumor so they use diluted whole
blood and they use a filtration device
that takes three minutes and they filter
out all of the the smaller cells and
leave the larger CDC's behind to be able
to care
enumerate those so a limitation with
this method is that not all CTCs have a
larger diameter there may be some that
flow through the filtration device are
lost so but this is interesting because
it captures them purely based on size
and then positively identify them after
that its enrichment based on size so
what are the current limitations in
circulating tumor cell utility so the
first one that I'll address is that I've
been talking about circulating tumor
cell denti fication is currently vary
based on epithelial markers the next one
that I'll talk about is methods most
methods don't allow you to capture a
visually identified cell so those method
that allow you to visually identify them
those cells usually must remain on the
cartridge so that's a negative aspect to
most isolation methods currently and
then lastly the FDA cleared method only
allows prognosis to be made on
enumeration of epithelial CTCs and we
would like to provide patients more
information about the nature of their
CTCs and provide a prognosis on the
characterization of that individual CTCs
why would a circulating tumor cell not
express at cam so typically on the left
is what epithelial cells tend to look
like they grow and tightly packed Rose
they have very strict requirements for
communication and growth and B cells
tend to be at Kim positive however it's
thought that a process known as
epithelial to mesenchymal transition
occurs in
answer this occurs not only in cancer
but also early on in development and
Austin wound healing so these cells
transition from this epithelial type
cell to a more missing komal cell that's
more elongated and is more highly mobile
these cells Express metella proteinases
that can chew through extracellular
matrix so it allows them to be to move
more freely and without the tight
requirements that are seen in epithelial
cells and these cells tend to express
let less f cam so it's either
down-regulated completely or there's a
very little expression of that came in
these cells and so why is this important
we've been able to see that there are
there's heterogeneity within CTCs not
only between patient to patient but even
within a patient from a single blood
draw so there is heterogeneity within
CTCs and then there's also the fact that
in metastatic breast cancer patients
forty percent of those patients have no
detectable CT cease using the current
methods that identify CTCs based on ab
cam and so we're interested in capturing
heterogeneous ETCs and being able to
find those CDC's in this forty percent
of metastatic breast cancer patients
that that currently have no detectable
CPC's and so in order to do that we've
developed a cell line method to capture
heterogeneous set of ctcs and we've
included a couple other positive markers
for identification so in addition to fkn
we've included cd44 which is a stem cell
marker and her to which is a marker of
of
rope so this is a flow cytometry plot so
this is our breast cancer cell line
model and we've intentionally chosen
cell lines to represent differences in
metastatic potential and different
molecular subtypes so on the y-axis will
be looking at came expression on the
x-axis cd44 expression so the first cell
line that we've chosen as a CTC subtype
is mcf-7 which is a luminal subtype they
express high levels of F cam and very
low levels of cd44 this is the lease
metastatic subtype that we've chosen to
include in our model the next is sk BR 3
which is a her to subtype it expresses
her too inept cam the next that has a
sort of intermediate metastatic
potential is a basal a subtype and it
expresses all three of the markers that
we've chosen for positive identification
and the last is MDA 230 ones which is a
basal be subtype it expresses cd44 and
is the most metastatic these metastatic
potentials are based on cell invasion
assays and how aggressively the cells
grow in culture and I'd like to point
out that because mda's produce a low
level of F cam the majority of them
would be missed by the current method
that capture cells that express AB cam
and these would potentially be the most
dangerous types of cells to a patient
because they're the most highly
aggressive subtype that we've chosen so
in some preliminary experiments that
we've done we've looked at the
separation efficiency or the specificity
of these four lines using those three
markers here's another flow plot that
we've look
this one the y axis is cd44 and the x
axis is her too so with these four cell
types we've determined the separation
efficiency using a hundred thousand ten
thousand a thousand and one hundred
cells and in repeated assays so we see a
high separation efficiency for mcf-7 and
sk br3 and then lower separation
efficiency for HTC and m das but overall
it's about 80% separation efficiency and
so to represent what we would see in a
patient sample we've done spiking
experiments where we spiked our four
cell line model into whole blood we then
perform a Phi called gradient to obtain
a buffy coat and then we negatively
deplete ourselves with a cd45 antibody
that has a magnet a magnetic bead
attached to it and that allows us to
deplete the unwanted hematopoietic cells
with the leukocytes and then we're left
with an enriched tumor sample the next
thing we do is then to treat those cells
with magnetic antibodies that are
conjugated to cd44 EPP cam and her to
and pass them through the column again
but this time and the flow through we
have our unwanted cells and our desired
cells remain attached at the side of the
magnet we then remove the the sample
from the magnetic apparatus and are left
with a highly enriched population of
desired cells
looking at that method we looked at the
MDA cells so the cells that are that
express upcam the least so they have
very low expression of that cam and we
determined in spiking experiments where
we spiked in a hundred thousand one
thousand or ten thousand and one
thousand cells into one mil of whole
blood we determined that the percent
recovery was eighty-five percent using
that method so now that I've discussed
how we are capturing a heterogeneous
population of ctcs now I'm going to
discuss the limitation that they're
currently most the methods do not allow
positive visual identification and then
the ability to retrieve that cell from
the cartridge so to combat that
limitation we have chosen to use a novel
technology known as the Deborah ray this
is produced by Silicon biosystems to
allow us to collect single viable CTCs
so this method allows cell trapping in
individual dielectrophoretic cages so
dielectrophoresis is the process by
which a neutral particles such as a cell
can experience a net force of movement
when it's exposed to a non-uniform
electric gradient and here's a schematic
of this individual dielectrophoretic
cage and one cell that's housed in it so
we can control the movement of these
cages which in turn allows us to isolate
these single cells so on the using the
dep array we can actually watch the cell
being sorted into the the container of
our choice so on the very right hand
side is a bright field image of a cell
that's trapped in this dielectrophoretic
cage and because dielectrophoresis is
a gentle method on the cells it allows
cells that are viable and these cells
were positive that we have what we're
looking for because we're able to
visually identify them and watch them on
the chip as they are sorted and and
provided to us so here's a cartoon of
this depper a cartridge so we add the
cells so this this would be an enriched
population of cells and we inject them
onto the cartridge there then sorted
into their individual dielectrophoretic
cages and we then visually identify
which cells that were interested in to
say I'm interested in this blue one and
this green one I then tell the
instrument to sort those cells to the
parking chamber and I watch them as they
are brought to the parking chamber and
say I want to look at the cells
individually um I have the cell sorted
individually into their own tubes and so
as far as I know this is the only method
that allows you to positively visually
identify cells before they're sorted
these cells can be grown in culture
following isolation these cells are
intact whole and viable and are
appropriate for downstream
characterization following this sort on
the Deborah ray so what have we done so
far with the Deborah ray what does this
allow us to do so in this experiment we
used a mixture of our four cell lines
and then we sorted them we loaded them
onto the Deborah ray and sort of them
using the Deborah ray so in this
schematic picture you're looking at one
cell that goes all the way across and
different channels
so this cell we were able to see is epic
am positive and expresses very little or
no her to cd44 so the the fuzzy
background indicates that we had a zoom
way in to see me signal so these are
essentially negative were or have very
little expression and then the bright
field shows the cell in its in its cage
so next we were able to identify a cell
that was epic am and her2 positive but
cd44 negative and again you see be the
cell in his bright field cage on the
right the next cell we were able to
identify was positive for all three
markers we were able to identify that it
was in its own cage so it was single and
Bible and lastly we found cells that
were negative for both at Kim and her
too but positive force in 244 so what
does this tell us it tells us that we
were able to sort from a mixture of
cells and determine what subtype of CDC
if you will and then also the metastatic
potential as we've as I've shown you
before mcf-7 has the least metastatic
potential and MDA 231 has the most
metastatic potential so using this
method we'd really be able to give a
better indication of the metastatic
potential of that individual's own ctcs
with this method and so lastly the
limitation that all focus on is that
currently prognosis is made based only
on an epithelial subtype and so we're
interested in combating this limitation
and providing more information to the
patient about their CDC's so in this
experiment we performed the enrichment
that I described earlier so we spike
cells into whole blood we do a negative
45 depletion and then a positive and
rich
mint we then can use either the dep
array or a single cell sorter a site
ometer to sort single cells and then
interrogate them on a single cell level
so this experiment we're looking at
transcript expression and so we've
devised some sort of an metastatic
potential based on transcript expression
so we gave points to each transcript
that we looked at and devised an
arbitrary score between 1 and 10 1 being
the lowest and 10 being the highest and
this was based on what's been observed
in the literature so in this plot on the
y-axis we're looking at metastatic
potential and those arbitrary units that
I just showed you and on the x-axis are
different CTC subtypes or the different
cell on populations and so looking at an
average mess attic potential of
traditionally isolated RNA and then
converted to cdna looking at a million
selves at a time we see that mcf-7 has
the lowest metastatic potential skb r3
and HTC 1954 have intermediate
metastatic potential and that MDA 231
has the highest metastatic potential and
this confirms thumb what's been reported
in the literature about e-cell limes so
here is the same graph that i just
showed looking at traditionally isolated
RNA or the average metastatic potential
but once we interrogate single cells
that have been sorted in a single cell
manner so each one of these represents
that on the y-axis the percent of single
cells and then on the x-axis we're
looking at metastatic potential going
from lowest to highest 10 being Louis
100 being the highest and so when we
look at
single mcf-7 cells we see that most of
them do have low metastatic potential
but within those cells some of them do
have a medicine cringe or 50 or 60 so
that's just indicating that there is
heterogeneity on a single cell level
from what was once thought to be a
homogeneous population of mcf-7 cells
and because we sorted these cells based
on their extracellular protein
expression it is a little bit surprising
that there's such a difference in
metastatic potential between these cells
but this is just confirming what's been
reported in the literature that single
tumors are heterogeneous and expression
and a patient's own CTCs within a single
blood draw are are heterogeneous and so
using this model will be able to
identify the heterogeneity in each
person and in each patient and provide
them metastatic potential for their
circulating tumor cells and so now that
I've shown you the cell line with the
least metastatic potential now let's
look at the at the salon or the subtype
with the most metastatic potential so
MDI to 30 ones are the most highly
metastatic cells so on the y-axis we're
looking at percent of single cells and
on the x-axis metastatic potential so
the majority of these cells do have high
metastatic potential 90 or 100 but a few
of the cells had lower so 40 or 20
metastatic potential so again this is um
characterizing the heterogeneity within
what was once thought to be a
homogeneous population so we're finding
unique subtypes within a single cell
line and those subtypes likely possess
different functional abilities and it's
really representative of the
heterogeneous etcs that were likely to
observe in a patient
and this really speaks to our ability to
to go from whole blood down to a single
CTC and characterize that that single
CTC to provide the patient with the most
individualized information about their
own CTCs so in summary I've shown
information indicating how we're
interested in identifying heterogeneous
CTCs and we're doing that by including a
few additional markers for positive
identification and identifying CDC
subtypes based on metastatic potential
we have discussed how we are able to
capture visually positively identified
cells using the dep array and then those
cells can then be used for further
downstream characterization to provide
the most information to a patient about
their CTCs and then lastly we're
combating that the prognosis is
currently made only on enumeration of
epithelial cells and we're looking to
expand prognosis to include
heterogeneous CTCs to provide the
patient with metastatic potential of
their single individual CTCs this will
provide the best therapeutic regimen for
the patient eventually we hope to get to
the point where we can identify what
tissue those CDC's are likely to
metastasize to so that essentially that
person can take prophylactic treatment
to prevent that but we really believe
that using this method will provide the
most individual information to a patient
about their own CTCs and what
therapeutic regimen would be best for
them
so of course you can obtain continuing
education credits by going to the bio
confidence live com website and I thank
you for your participation in your
attendance this is a schematic of our
cardinal bird in louisville and one of
the buildings that i work in so thank
you so much for your attention and i'll
i'll answer questions now so one of the
questions that has been posed is isn't a
challenge to ascertain statistically
significant heterogeneity and 100 CTCs
um I think that there will be if there
are 100 CTCs in a patient sample I think
that there will be easily statistically
significant information about a
patient's heterogeneity I don't think
that that would be I don't think that
that would pose too much of a challenge
to prove that it was statistically
significant see some its other questions
there's a question about how many
dielectrophoretic cages are on the chip
so the chip houses 80,000 cages so we
our sample must be enriched enough to
have less than 80,000 cells cell search
is used for um
breast cancer as well as a for colon
cancer and for prostate cancer so this
question was asking if if CDC's detected
by cell search can apply to other
cancers and it's really just those three
epithelial cancers so far but many other
studies are looking at trying to
identify CTCs in lung cancer and other
cells that other cancers that aren't
epithelial nature so this question asks
why are we discarding ab cam low- cells
during the enrichment procedure so we're
not discarding those cells we're keeping
those cells as well we're just expanding
the number of positive markers that will
be available to detect those CTCs and
this last question looks like they're
asking about next generation sequencing
use for analysis of to tc's and yes i
think that that will be routinely used
in the near future we're working on
there's a question here about
sensitivity and accuracy of the dep
array show us I showed that we have
about eighty five percent yield but
we're working on looking at accuracy
over many studies for capturing CTCs and
it looks like that's about it for the
questions so I thank you so much for
your attendance and I wish you all
success in your scientific endeavors
thank you